Judy this is bad I won't repeat that
obviously I agree and we were with the
Bloomberg foundation the major funder of
all of this so clearly I think that this
is a very critical thing to do and we
really want to spread this to cities all
across the United States but let me talk
about other kinds of structures than
volunteerism which is is extraordinarily
important and and return to the role of
a university because I I think
universities in order to train it
students to be good citizens need to be
good citizens themselves so the
university needs to be a role model for
civic engagement it needs to create
opportunities for civic engagement and
one structural way to do that is through
service learning courses courses that
really do take the theoretical knowledge
in the classroom and also create a
mechanism for students to be able to see
how they can translate that on the
ground and not every course is amenable
to that not every professor finds that a
particularly valuable application but
really probing where and how that can
happen I'll give you one example and
Penn now has over a hundred of these and
they're not soft minded courses they're
not you know guts it since you're taking
econ that semester and it's hard they
really got some of them are really from
the hardest courses so the intro to
geology a course taught by a Bob gigging
gac one of pens teaching stars has a
service learning component and the
student select that additional component
they don't have to take it when they
take geology 101 but the service
learning component has the
undergraduates in the course then going
out into the community and working with
middle school kids to identify sources
of lead poisoning in very poor homes in
neighborhood and then they give the
families the information they teach them
what they can do to mitigate they've
developed a really great map of the
epidemiology of lead poisoning in West
Philadelphia which has fed back and
helped a lot of the Public Health
investigators and so they really are
learning okay I now know about geology
so I've learned about lead and now I'm
figuring out how I can apply that in a
way that provides service for others
that's a really important structural
tangible thing again not everything is
applied I to believe in theoretical
knowledge but where it can be it's
really valuable and it sets your mind in
a different course because then you're
always inquiring analytically you know
how could I apply what I learned maybe
there is a different way of thinking
about this maybe there's a new way and
you if you do that you can shift
paradigms as well because some of the
traditional ways that we've thought
about delivering service haven't always
been as effective and we're also in a
21st century model so even if they were
effective in the last century we may
need different ways of thinking about it
now I think these courses are one
mechanism we're doing that yeah I yes um